vor kurzem haben wir ein video gemacht
mit 20 sätzen zu dem werk gehen
heute gehen wir noch einen schritt
weiter und zeigen euch werben mitgehen
und einem präfix im deutschen gibt es
über 30 präfix die mit dem verb stamm
gehen kombiniert werden können
heute zeigen wir euch jedoch nur die
werden die am häufigsten benutzt werden
manche werden sind leicht zu verstehen
da sie mit einer lokalen präposition
kombiniert werden und man sie sehr
wörtlich übersetzen kann zum beispiel
zurückgehen
die asg zurück
oder weggehen janus geht weg
oder vorbeigehen janus geht an mir
vorbei oder draufgehen
ich gehe die treppe rauf runter gehen
ich gehe die treppe runter
einige werben kann man jedoch nicht so
wirklich verstehen hier sind ein paar
beispiele abgehen jumping ist henning
harnisch was geht heute abend ab nichts
geht ab ich bleiben heute zuhause
untergehen to go down to set gehen
arbeit unter
die sonne geht gleich unter die flasche
geht im wasser unter umgehend die
lamping organisch ist so gestresst
ich weiß nicht wie ich damit umgehen
soll
[Musik]
er kann mit stress einfach nicht umgehen
aufgehen to go up to raise jeden morgen
geht die sonne auf
ich sehe es aber nie
denn ich schlafe ausgehen
something is being switch stoff angehen
allerdings war das richtig ausgegangen
was du woran das liegt ja ich habe es
ausgemacht
jetzt geht das licht wieder an
ja weil ich es an gemacht habe rausgehen
zulieferer kloster janisch geht aus dem
haus raus rein gehen zu enttarnen
building auf es ist kalt vor allem
reingehen
ja okay geht in das haus ein
[Musik]
ausgehen und rausgehen kann auch
bedeuten
wir benutzen ausgehen wenn es offiziell
und etwas feiner ist rausgehen benutzen
wir jedoch häufiger im alltäglichen
sprachgebrauch wollen wir heute abend
ausgehen
ach ja was machen wir denn wir gehen
schick essen und dann in die oper wollen
wir heute abend rausgehen
warum willst du denn wir können beim
griechen essen und dann in die kneipe um
die ecke
ok jemandem fremdgehen teams amore
der mann ist seiner frau fremd gegangen
die frau geht daraufhin auch fremd dann
lassen sie sich scheiden
fuchs damit konnte keiner rechnen
mitgehen konnte
ich muss morgen früh zum bürgeramt
kennst du mit gehen uns für mich
übersetzte jetzt losgehen to start
walking oder zu beginn ok wollen wir mal
losgehen
ich muss noch einkaufen jetzt können wir
los gehen kommen schnell janisch das
spiel gleich los eingehen
meine pflanze geht bald ein weil ich sie
nie diese ich gehe hier noch ein vor
langeweile vorgehen to go ahead
dubai sid
wie gehen wir jetzt in der sache vorher
weiß ich auch nicht
es ist kompliziert gehen wir essen ja
noch die agiere
[Musik]
du bist mir zu langsam ich hier schon
vor
kaputtgehen to break scheiße der
staubsauger ist kaputt gegangen
na gut dann bleibt es wohl dreckig
weitergehen to continue to proceed die
werbung ist vorbei der film geht weiter
das war unser video zu den häufigsten
pre fixen die man mit dem werbe gehen
verwendet jetzt könnt ihr noch übungen
zu diesen werben machen werdet einfach
ein patchen und erhalte zugang zu über
100 online übungen
außerdem könnt ihr noch wie sie germany
abonnieren
darüber freuen wir uns sehr panische ich
gehe jetzt weg und warten auf eure
klicks